Howie Mandel yes thanks Howie Mandel
with behind Mandel comedy club yes
you're very happy with how the special
came out I got to tell you I am such a
huge fan of mine all right
I go I go to just about every show I do
I don't miss anything yeah I think
listen I'm also a talent judge so I sit
back and I watch myself and I golden
buzzer myself I'm going right about
America's Got Talent quickly how is it
that you've survived other people are on
the show and then they're off the show
you know Mel B's on the show and Heidi
Klum that Heidi Klum they're on the show
but then they're gone God you seem to
survive what's your secret
I'm affordable how much almost nothing
you know you do I am so much less than
every other gasps people don't realize
if you'd like to spend some time with me
I'm on Groupon and you couldn't you
could clip coupons and you can have me
show up anywhere I'd in the dark I will
do that anyway the truth is we do have
this is a great new season of America's
Got Talent
the MLB is going on a Spice Girls tour
Heidi Klum is doing a huge show on
Amazon so we have two new judges
julianne hough and Gabrielle Union
they're wonderful were in the midst of
the season it's going to be a
spectacular knockout season on a GT Deal
or No Deal is still on CNBC this guy Bob
animals doing things I also have a
festival to what's jfl must be honest
I'm a laughs I'm one of the partners yes
you are Anna festival I've got a club
and right after this I'm gonna get
myself an egg salad sandwich
Oh No howie mandel presents Allen Mandel
what the hell I'm in Dale comedy club is
available now through the comedy
dynamics Network on iTunes Amazon Prime
and Google Play check that out Howie
Mandel no one doesn't like
[Applause]